-Congratulations
on your Emmy nomination.
It's very exciting.
-It is exciting.
-So, this show was inspired
by a book you wrote in 2015,
"Troublemaker," that sort of
detailed your experience
with the Church of Scientology.
-Sorry. I'm futzing
because I just ripped my dress
in the dressing room.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-Do you think -- Do you think --
Did the Scientologists do it?
-No, I think --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's a plot, it's a plot.
Yeah, so,
it was actually inspired
from other people
telling their stories.
-Because once you wrote --
Is it fair to say, safe to say,
that once you wrote your book
about your experience,
you were approached
by a lot of other people
that had a similar experience?
-Well, yes, but also, you know,
it's one thing
to leave Scientology.
It's another thing
to speak out publicly,
and I knew
that I had to do that,
because Scientology
has a policy that if you leave,
you can leave, but you just
have to leave quietly.
If you publicly speak out,
then they label you an enemy,
and then they start to attack.
So I knew
that I had to do something
to let people know on the
outside that I was with them.
-And one of the things
you talk about
that came up a lot
in the first season
is this idea of disconnecting.
Can you explain what that is
and how Scientology uses that?
-Yes. Like I said,
if you leave and speak publicly,
then anybody in your family,
all your friends,
would have
to disconnect from you.
They shun you, basically.
And so that's
what disconnection is.
And I was seeing that
over and over again.
Of course, I knew the policies
of Scientology when I --
'Cause I was raised in it.
But I actually
never saw it happen.
You know, you grow up
in Scientology thinking
"It's us against them"
mentality.
And it's a slow indoctrination
into this brainwashing cult.
But I should probably be kinder
so early on in the show, but --
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you do --
Now, you have --
You know, it seems like there is
more and more information
about what Scientology is
and I think maybe
a little bit warning about it
more than there were
in previous years.
Yet it seems to be,
according to you,
that people within Scientology
are not exposed
to that information.
How does Scientology
sort of control
what people within it
are exposed to
and what they're reading?
-Good question. Uh...
Yeah.
Sit on that for a second.
How -- How does it happen?
It happens by, very early on
in your indoctrination,
this mentality that
"It's us against them."
Don't read the newspapers.
Don't watch television.
Don't listen
to critics of Scientology."
And they have all this
information on people who leave.
They were
doing weird things with animals.
They have packets on them.
You're like, "Wha?
Joe was doing that?"
And so they're, like,
"yeah, you can't call him,
though, to verify it,
because if you call Joe
and ask him..."
-Yeah.
We've one of those guys here.
-Oh, you do?
[ Light laughter ]
His name Joe?
-I shouldn't say, but...
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know, you're not allowed
to speak to people
once they leave,
so there's no verifying
that information.
If you do call them,
then you're interrogated
at your expense,
and you're put
on a lie detector.
So there's
a lot of repercussions
to looking outside of the
organization for information.
And so you're just
not allowed to do that.
Does that answer the question,
or are you still like,
"Yeah, but why didn't
you still look?"
-No.
And I understand.
Certainly, also, it seems,
what you're stressing,
which makes a lot of sense,
is this all happens slowly.
Obviously, you, I think,
were raised into it,
but people get into it
even later in life.
-Yes.
-It must seem like
a very nice, helpful thing.
I can't imagine your early time
in Scientology is negative.
-No, of course.
In the beginning, it's like
you learn how to talk to people.
Look at them in the eye
when you're talking to them.
You do little courses
on finances
and how to achieve your goals.
You know, $35, $45 courses.
And as you go on, you know,
as you go proposition --
right? --
you're in at $250,000
by the time you're done,
and I'm being, again, very kind.